Benoît et facteur de clavecin c'est lui
qui s'occupe de l'entretien du clavecin
vieux de 250 ans situé dans la chapelle
du monastère du Bon Pasteur un
instrument rare au Canada il appréhende
les dommages peut-être impossible à
réparer certaines pièces maîtresses d'un
instrument si on change ces pièces-là
supposons la table d'harmonie admettons
que celle-là pas fait
on perd un peu l'instrument parce que
parce que c'est elle qui donne sa
personnalité c'est elle qu'on veut
particulièrement qui vieillissent
classer édifice patrimonial le monastère
du Bon Pasteur est unique de 1886 au
milieu des années 60 les soeurs de la
communauté de Notre-Dame du Bon Pasteur
il dirige un pensionnat ainsi qu'un
centre pour jeunes filles en difficulté
en 1979 les soeurs vendent le monastère
au gouvernement du Québec qui le classe
monument historique cependant ce n'est
qu'en 1984 que Québec cède le bâtiment à
la Ville de Montréal
quelques années plus tard à l'initiative
du maire Jean Doré une société
paramunicipale est mandatée pour le
restaurer Clément Demers a été le
directeur général de ce bâtiment
entièrement remis à neuf au milieu des
années 80 ce projet est unique et
exceptionnel puis était présenté un peu
partout dans le monde il abrite
actuellement en divers organismes ainsi
qu'une résidence pour aînée et une salle
de concert grâce à un financement propre
à chacun des partenaires ce qui le
distingue des autres édifices
patrimoniaux beaucoup plus en continuité
avec le sens du bâtiment à l'origine
c'est-à-dire c'était un service à la
communauté et ce bâtiment là reste un
service à la communauté puis aussi un
repère sur le plan culturel et sur le
plan communautaire l'édifice héberge
entre autres l'organisme
Héritage Montréal qui souligne
l'avant-gardiste de ce projet de
rénovation à l'époque vraiment le type
de projet exactement de projet mixtes de
cohabitation qu'on comprend encore
aujourd'hui c'était vraiment le grand
pionnier c'est vraiment un lieu
exemplaire
Clément interpelle les élus et le milieu
des affaires ne peut pas résister vacant
à l'abandon c'est impossible il faut
qu'il se passe quelque chose c'est sûr
il garde tout de même espoir ce bâtiment
est trop ancré dans le paysage pour
perdre son envergure croît-il ici
Marie-Josée paquet de Comores au Canada
Montréal